-Our next guest is featured
in season 3 of
"The Standups" available on
Netflix this December.
Please welcome the very funny
Dusty Slay!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright. Okay.
We're having a good time.
And okay.
Well, I'm pumped to be here.
People always tell me I look
like somebody, you know?
They're always like,
"You look like Joe Dirt."
Or "You look like
'Wayne's World.'"
[ Laughter ]
"You look like
Jay and Silent Bob."
[ Laughter ]
One guy was like, "You look like
a Walmart Billy Ray Cyrus."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Dang, I didn't know
you could get more Walmart
than Billy Ray Cyrus."
[ Laughter ]
I thought that was
as Walmart as it got.
But people always tell me
I look just like their cousin.
They're always like,
"You look just like my cousin.
Just like my cousin."
And then every time
they show me a picture,
it's never a good-looking dude.
[ Laughter ]
I'm always -- I'm never like,
"Man, I appreciate that."
I'm always like, "That's what
you think I look like?
That's how I look to you?"
You ever see
a bad picture of yourself
and you know that
you don't look like that?
[ Laughter ]
But also deep down inside
you know that you did
look like that?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I mean, like, that camera
didn't make that up, right?
Like, it might have caught you
in a bad moment,
but that's you in that picture.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the question you got to ask
yourself is
"How often am I looking
like that?
And what do I got to do to never
look like that again?"
But people always think
I know about cars.
They think I look like a guy
that knows a lot about cars.
And they'll always ask me to
listen to their car
to see what's wrong with it,
you know?
And I'll do it.
You know what I mean?
Like, I don't want to let them
down, right?
So I'll listen. I go, "Ooh.
You should get that checked out,
man."
[ Laughter ]
And if you do it just right,
they'll be like, "You know what?
I will get it checked out.
I appreciate that.
I wasn't. But I will now."
And I know a little bit
about cars
'cause I wrecked
a bunch of them.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like if you wreck enough,
you learn what a car can do,
what it can't do.
What it can't come back from,
you know?
And for a while I was driving
a 1982 Buick LeSabre.
[ Man cheers]
Alright.
Real big car, you know?
Used a lot of gas.
And I used to make this joke
at work.
I'd be like,
"Man, that car uses so much gas,
I bet it's using gas right now
in the parking lot."
[ Laughter ]
That's a great work joke.
People love that.
One guy didn't get it, though.
He goes,
"Hell, you might have a leak."
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"No, I don't think so."
But I did have a car that leaked
a lot of oil for a while.
And I like that in a car.
Like, you leak a little oil,
pour a little in there.
Leak a little oil,
Never get an oil change.
[ Laughter and applause ]
People are like, "When is
the last time you changed
the oil on this car?"
I'm like,
"It's changing right now."
[ Laughter ]
Okay? This car is efficient.
I used to drive that car
all over the country.
You know, leaking oil
everywhere.
I drove up to Duluth, Minnesota,
one time.
-Yeah!
-Alright.
And I went to this aquarium.
I don't know if you've been
there before.
I don't know if I'd go
just for the aquarium,
but if you're up there,
check it out.
It was a nice place, but it just
felt like the aquarium
was on a two-week notice, right?
[ Laughter ]
They're like, "We about to shut
this place down."
Like, some animals were missing.
There was a fountain
that had dried up.
There was a turtle in there.
I didn't know if it was ceramic
or if it had just stopped
moving.
[ Laughter ]
And they had a walk-in bird cage
that you could walk into.
But I got in there,
and it just felt like
it was birds from the outside.
[ Laughter ]
Like, I know all birds are
from the outside.
But it felt like you were in,
like, a retail store
and a bird had just flown in
and then couldn't figure
how to get out.
And then I went to
the main aquarium
and I'm looking at
the fish tank, right?
And there's a lot of fish
in there.
And this girl comes up to me
and she has a name tag on.
And the name tag has her name,
and then it says "fish expert."
I was like, "Alright, that's
what I'm talking about."
You know what I mean?
I don't run into a lot of
fish experts out
here in the world.
And I thought, "This is a great
time to get some answers
to some of the fish questions
that I have."
[ Laughter ]
So I started asking her
some stuff,
you know, stuff I can Google.
But I thought, "Hey, let's have
a real human experience here."
So I start asking her stuff, and
then I say, "Oh, you know what?
I got a good one."
This is a good question.
You're going to like this.
This is what I said to her.
I go, "Let me ask you this.
Do fish sleep?"
That's what I said to her.
I said, "Do fish sleep?"
And she looked me straight
in the face and she goes,
"I don't know 'cause I don't
work here at night."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay, hey, thank you very much,
guys.
I appreciate you. Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
-Dusty Slay, everybody.
Dusty Slay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Season 3 of "The Standups" is
out December on Netflix.